ganz viele von ihnen die platten gerade
die blanke angst die blanke
existenzangst ja wenn die neue
gasrechnung dann in die briefkästen
trudel viele fragen sich wie lange das
noch bezahlen
warum wird er ganz aufschlag auf die
kunden umgelegt den verbockt wurde ist
er von unserer regierung die letzten
jahre man hat sich mit putin in russland
verlassen wird für mich als verbraucher
gemacht damit ich mir das noch leisten
kann im winter meine wohnung zu heizen
und mein auto zu fahren der sprache um
zur arbeit zu kommen wird es irgendwann
auch wieder gas geben dass man zahlen
kann wie werden die gaslieferungen
eigentlich überhaupt gesteuert hast du
schon mal wirklich die ganze nacht
gefroren werden noch mal bessere zeiten
auf uns zu kommen wer soll das bezahlen
ja wann hört dieser ganze scheiß auf
ja das fragen wir uns auch hier so viele
fragen von ihnen die wir gleich
versuchen zu beantworten in italien
versuchen ganz viele gaskunden diese
antwort zu geben sie verbrennen einfach
ihre gasrechnung dort vor dem rathaus in
neapel wütende italienische gaskunden
und diesen minuten der jubel auf den
straßen weil das eben als einfache und
im moment einzige lösung gilt die
gasrechnung nicht zu zahlen sie einfach
dort vom rathaus zu verbrennen und zwar
kanzler der sagt dazu muss es in
deutschland nicht kommen der dieser
antwort an uns
you never walk alone
also ist es keiner alleine wir hoffen
darauf
und wir sprechen auch darüber was sie
machen können denn eins ist sicher wir
lassen sie nicht alleine und wir sind
jetzt auch nicht mehr allein der spaß
ochs ist bei uns frank ochse mit den
besten tipps die man so haben kann wenn
jetzt im briefkasten so eine horror
rechnung landet also ganz wichtig erst
mal sich einen überblick verschaffen
da wird natürlich auch zum teil wirklich
auch getrickst und da wird einfach mal
so eine preiserhöhung rausgehauen also
wirklich erst mal schauen wer steht denn
auch in diesem schreiben wirklich drin
das ist mein alter preis und das ist der
neue preis und dann kann man natürlich
schon mal sehen er ist das
gerechtfertigt wir müssen davon ausgehen
wir haben zurzeit bei neuverträgen ein
preis von 40 cent pro
kubikmeter gas
kilowattstunde gas und dann kann ich
natürlich sehen ist das jetzt quasi
angemessen wir haben wirklich auch in
der redaktion drastische hilferufe
bekommen wo wirklich massiv auch zu
gelegt worden ist und ich behaupte jetzt
ohne wirklich alle schreiben zu können
die hälfte ist möglicherweise überhöht
danke frank für den moment kommt gleich
zu dir zurück holen dazu den
verbraucheranwalt arndt kempgens hierbei
bild live kuss sie herzlich herr
kempinski haben gerade diese bilder aus
italien gesehen und das ist ja nicht nur
ein aufstand dort von wütenden
italienischen gaskunden sondern dahinter
steckt schlicht die frage was mache ich
eigentlich nicht einfach gar nicht
zahlen kann die sind verzweifelt
verbrennen ihre gasrechnung was passiert
eigentlich in so einem moment wenn man
ihn in deutschland steht die gasrechnung
kommt von mehreren tausend euro
möglicherweise und man sagt hat er
freunde ich kann es halt gar nicht
zahlen ich zahle nicht
also bitte auf keinen fall so kopf in
den sand stecken bitte auf keinen fall
die rechnung verbrennen und nichts
machen das kann natürlich ein
symbolischer akt sein da kann man auch
seine wut vielleicht ablassen aber man
sollte unbedingt mit dem versorger
direkt kontakt aufnehmen damit es eben
nicht zu sperrungen kommt also bitte
unbedingt kommunizieren unbedingt eben
versorger ansprechen und wenn man kein
geld hat dann gibt es auch sozial mittel
die man dann auch wirklich ohne scheu
beantragen sollte wenn ich jetzt als
allererstes in den briefkasten schau und
kriegst du einen brief mit einer
rechnung die ich nicht bezahlen kann was
sollten so die ersten schritte seien
frank ochs ist ja hier bei uns im studio
hat gerade darauf hingewiesen wirklich
sich da die mühe zu machen ganz genau
hinzuschauen ganz genau zu lesen aber
erst muss ich achten
da hat frank usa absolut recht man muss
erstmal natürlich gucken ist dieser
dieses schreiben wird der
preisunterschied genau dargestellt dann
gibt es fristen die einzuhalten sind wir
brauchen also mindestens ein monat der
vorher eben ein vorlauf hat damit der
verbraucher darauf vorbereitet wird dann
auch mal die eigenen verträge gucken es
gibt ja die grundversorgung wenn ich
also kein sondervertrag habe und dann
gibt es sonderverträge und bitte mal die
verträge alle völlig unterschiedlich
bitte da mal reinschauen gibt es
vielleicht sogar eine preisgarantie und
dann kann ich mich natürlich auch darauf
berufen wie kann das überhaupt sein
frank du hast das gerade gesagt dass so
viele versorger im moment überhöhte
rechnung schicken unser spar volks frank
oxy wie kann das sein in so einer zeit
wo die menschen so verzweifelt sind das
dann die versorger nicht das feingefühl
für all ihre kunden haben und sagen
mensch den können wir jetzt nicht noch
mehr zumuten das ist doch eigentlich
unmenschlich also ich sage natürlich die
seriösen versorger die kalkulieren schon
sehr sehr gut und da glaube ich einfach
auch bei den grundversorgern dass das
alles stimmt aber zum beispiel bei den
anderen versorgung da gibt es immer
wieder schwarze schafe und die sagen
sich ich möchte diesen kunden auch gar
nicht mehr haben also ich möchte ihnen
rausekeln ich möchte ihn rausgenommen
und weil sich der kunde vielleicht für
mich nicht mehr rechnen und ich möchte
halt meinen gewinn steigern dann ist das
wirklich auch eine möglichkeit wirklich
die leute raus zu kommen und wir es halt
nicht merkt er bezahlt deshalb deswegen
ganz wichtig tatsächlich genau anschauen
was da drin steht und dann wenn es
einfach zu viel ist wenn die rechnung zu
hoch ist dann sofort das
kündigungsschreiben losschicken herr
campions empfang ist der zeitpunkt
gekommen an dem ich mir hilfe holen muss
an dem ich jemanden wie sie brauchen in
dem ich mehr rechtlichen beistand holen
muss die summe eine hohe summe alleine
reicht da nicht
das stimmt das ist tatsächlich etwas
schwer zu beantworten denn auch das
kündigen muss man sich natürlich genau
überlegen frage ob sie sagt ja zu recht
kündigung überlegen mal gucken ob man
anderen versorger findet der dann eben
günstiger ist aber das ist natürlich im
moment wahnsinnig schwer denn alle
versorger haben ja probleme preise
anzubieten und deswegen kann es auch
sinnvoll sein das man erstmal unter
vorbehalt zahlen um eben die sperrung zu
verhindern wenn nämlich die preise zu
hoch erhöht werden das muss ja begründet
werden und wenn die begründung ja nicht
überzeugend ist dann bitte den abschlag
zahlen aber dazu schreiben auf den
überweisungsträger oder im über
online-portale eben unter vorbehalt und
dann kann ich später halt überlegen ob
ich das zurückfordern das kann man dann
eben gemeinsam überlegen aber damit ist
zumindest erstmal die sperre abgewendet
das sind total wertvolle ratschläge vor
allen dingen protest einzulegen
beschwerde einzulegen um das geld zu
kämpfen und trotzdem ist das ja ein
langwieriger prozess deswegen der
normalfall wird ja sein im moment kommt
halt die abschlagszahlung auf und man
kann das erst mal gar nicht bedienen die
rechnung sind einfach so hoch man hat
nichts auf der hohen kante deswegen ich
warte weiter auf eine antwort was man
eigentlich in diesem fall macht man kann
auch einfach das gar nicht bedienen oder
erkämpft ist
das ist tatsächlich ein problem und
deswegen sind ja auch die politischen
ebenen gefragt da etwas zu machen es
gibt ja den vorstoß der
mehrwertsteuerreduzierung die einen
ganzen teil dieser erhöhung auffangen
würde zumindest dieser umlage man geht
ja so davon aus nach rechnung der
verbraucherzentrale das so 500 euro sein
können für normale familie und die
mehrwertsteuer ersparen ist also wenn
die mehrwertsteuer reduziert wird dann
wären das etwa so zwei drittel was man
dadurch sparen würde also dass politik
gefragt es muss schnell rettungsschirme
geben gerade für die einkommensschwachen
familien
danke an an kempkens verbraucheranwalt
und danke vor allen dingen auch an
unseren sparfuchs frank ochse hier
vielen dank
[Musik]